Okay so the plan today was just going to be to
talk about kind of how Shiny actually renders
things, which is I think often we've sort of
thought about it as like a maybe not exactly
an advanced topic but not something you would sort
of start with right away, and I think overall it's
actually really useful to have like a just
better understanding of the like how things
actually get rendered and how Shiny does its
tricks. And this is more important for Python.
In a lot of ways like this is what I'm going to
talk about, is totally applicable to both R and
Python. They work exactly the same way, but on
the R side of things, like when I was starting
as a Shiny developer, it was just kind of like
the way that you developed web applications. I
didn't really think about it being a weird way to
develop applications or a magical or great way of
developing them , but it really is so these
are slides that I'm just going to use for,
from the workshop that I gave at posit::conf,
and so this is a little Shiny app here,
and if you've kind of used Shiny at all, you might
be familiar with sort of how like the experience
of things re-rendering. So I have these two
plots that are both driven by this slider,
so there's you know this slider whenever to
make a change both of these plots re-render,
but if I change this slider, the only plot
that renders is this one, so nothing actually
happens with this, with this plot, in the
same way you know if you have a multi-page
Shiny app, the only, the only plot the
only, part of that will, that will render,
the ones that are actually active, and the
question is like how does Shiny do that,
like how how actually is is it working? In
particular if you look at this is the Python
code for that application that, the this is
the sort of total amount of code for how those
plots are rendered. There's this kind of weird
quality here if you're thinking about this from,
from traditional web development framework which
is that, you know, we told Shiny what to do but
we didn't tell it when to do it, so there's
no call backs here, there's nothing saying
like when this changes in this way you know
fire this function or anything like that it
just kind of knows and actually seems to usually
do a really, really good job at that knowledge.
So, how does it work, and maybe we're thinking
like how other frameworks work. So Streamlit
has this approach of re-rendering everything all
the time. Some of these other Python frameworks
like Dash, Panel and Gradio focus more on
like defining a callback function which is,
is often referred to as event driven programming.
So what event driven programming means is that you
actually tell the, you're you're the developer
responsible for telling things when to fire,
when to rerender so you're responding to an event,
and it's great in a lot of ways because it's,
it's a very natural way to think, like you sort
of are thinking about connecting the wire from
one particular trigger to one particular output,
and if you kind of do that enough times, you can
get really wonderful interactions, but there's a
few different problems with it, like one is you
kind of have to do it like it's, it's a little bit
more work. I think it's pretty easy to get wrong
especially if you have something like two elements
are both up, should be updated, by one call back
and you forget to do one of them. You can end up
with your application in this kind of weird state,
and it's easy to make those types of mistakes and
most importantly it's really easy to, it's hard
to sometimes, hard to tell that you've gotten
it wrong so with like event driven programming,
like a big failure state, is just that one of the
numbers in your application is incorrect, or one
of the values is incorrect, rather than getting
like a big loud failure, so those things are
kind of some of the classic problems with them.
So a better way, and this is how Shiny does it,
is to infer the relationships between components,
and then to build a computation graph to figure
out how those things should be rendered so when
you, if I knew the relationship between all the
different components, I could draw basically a
directed acylic graph, kind of like airflow or
something, or make and just update the downstream
elements. Whenever the upstream elements change,
and I have a really good model for being able to
render things super efficiently and render large
things super efficiently, so if I kind of, you
ever hear somebody tell you that like I have this
magic way of inferring some sort of thing from
your application, you know like check your wallet
or something, like it's often like a little bit of
a Fool's Gold, like if you find this suspicious or
don't trust that, that's probably like a good
sign, because for it to work it has to work
all the time like it's not gonna. It's not good
enough to just have something like 80% of the time
it gets the right relationship but sometimes it
misses one. It needs to be like really reliable,
and we we know this works because it's worked so
well on our side for so long. You know it's like
a long time of people using this exact pattern
to build very, very complicated applications that
have lasted a long time and the sort of underlying
mechanism once you get a handle on it is it kind
of is obvious in some ways and it's it's easy to
to work with, but one of the things is it's not
static code analysis. So, this is like one of the
common misconceptions about Shiny, is that Shiny
is actually like reading your source code and
drawing those reactive links that way, and that's
not how it's working. Instead it uses something
called runtime tracing. I just want to give you an
example of why static code analysis wouldn't work,
and the reason is, there's a bunch of reasons,
like one is hard and you know, it's like there's a
lot of ways you can get it wrong, but let's say we
did a really really good static code analyzer to
generate stuff there's still some cases in Shiny
that it just is impossible. So this is an example
where the user is actually writing text that is
Python code to generate outputs. So it's this, is
a select thing, but you could easily imagine this
being a text input, and Shiny is able, I'm able to
write an application that responds to that text.
One way of thinking about this is that the way
that the run, the way this application is running,
it actually depends not just on what's in the
source code, but actually also how the person
is using that source code. So this is the
the code that generates that, and if you're
you know if you're an R user, this you could do
the same thing with some kind of like, you know,
with with eval as well like you know if you're
doing any kind of meta programming or anything
on R, you would run into that same situation,
so you see here. Like this is what if we did
had a static code analyzer this is what we would
analyze right we wouldn't be analyzing what's in
the user input because we don't know what that is
right, but this application for it to run properly
actually needs to respond to that user input and
there's a lot of kind of dynamic user interfaces,
that you could build with Shiny that static code
would fail. So runtime tracing is a different
strategy and basically what it is is you just want
to ask watch what all the components ask for and
keep track track of that so whenever somebody a
component runs it's going to ask for some things
if you keep track of those things, you know that
when those things change that component needs to
be rendered. So basically you just watch for those
components, keep track of those relationships and
then build this computation graph, so here's a
little example of some of this. So we have just
kind of highlight with a little code so you can
sort to think of these as like recipes so there's
like a connection between this output and this
ing function so this is like text and text and
there's also a connection between the inputs and
the input elements. So this is, this is, basically
this renderer is saying like, so we know that
basically like when the user opens up this app and
it's asking for the output of this text uh output,
we know that that's connected. They're sort of
asking for this text renderer so we can draw one
link there and then we know that when this text
renderer runs it's asking asking for this input
n, and this is, this can be dynamic right we
don't need to actually look at the code for that
we can sort of keep track of the component when
it's running to see what it actually is asking
for. So this can give you a little reactive graph
on like this so slider recipe text, and then
I'm just going to shorten that to be input to
output. So that's kind of like the, the overall
strategy, and this kind of leads this the term for
this programming is this type of programming call
it declarative programming, is what Hadley calls
it in the Shiny book, which I think is really
good. And so what you're doing is you're like
telling Shiny what, what should be generated, but
you're not, but you're trusting that the framework
is going to keep everything up to date, and I just
watched the bear which is this great TV show about
menus and so this is like you're setting the
menu you're not cooking, and if you've ever
seen that show there's like when the head chef is
like in the weeds, cooking yelling, yelling very
stressful and then at some point later in the show
he becomes he like gets the restaurant in a good
enough state that he can kind of like just handle
setting the menu, and and not worry so much about
the, the the sort of details right. So, in this
case, like you want this to be you. You want to
be this person, not this person right. And that's
how Shiny works. It's expecting you to just tell
us what to do, and then trust it to render things
properly. So, this is that application again,
and if we think about this, there's like two
inputs, there's this slider and this checkbox
and then there's two outputs. There's a outputs,
there's a plot and a distribution plot, and if
you look at it it would look something like this
so you have two outputs, two inputs, and let me
just see the chat here, make sure I'm not missing
anything, and then at the beginning shiny doesn't
know anything about the relationships between
these components. I'll just zoom in a bit that's
actually not gonna work. It doesn't know anything
about the relationships between these components
it just knows that they exist, and the first thing
it does is it just picks one of these outputs,
and it says let's calculate this output, and when
it calculates the output this is going to ask for
checkbox and slider and Shiny is going to watch
that, and and say okay last time you ran you asked
for checkbox and slider, so I know that you have
a dependency on those time, those two things right
now, and it's going to go over to the dis plot
and see that the dis plot only asks for slider,
doesn't ask for check checkbox. And here we have
the DAG for this application. It's a very very
simple DAG, but this same process scales up to
kind of an arbitrarily large number of nodes. Okay
so what happens, when a slider changes so when the
slider changes, we know that there's a dependency
here so we can follow those down and say these two
things need to, are called invalidated, so they
need to be re recalculated and then it forgets
all the dependencies that goes into it. It says
okay whatever I knew in the past might not be true
anymore, so I'm just going to totally forget about
it, and then it recalculates. In this case it
generates the same graph, but it doesn't have to,
it could generate a different graph depending
on your application. Like at runtime, it's
it's sort of on the fly figuring out all those
relationships based on what things have asked for,
what okay, so then everything's updated. If we
ask for the checkbox, we change the checkbox,
does the same thing it follows this down says oh
there's a scatter plot there last time we ran that
asked for the scatter plot so that's going to
be out of date need to rerun the scatter plot
renderer. So I'm going to forget the dependencies
from the scatter plot, but I don't since I'm since
this disc plot is fine, I don't need to change
any of those things I don't need to do anything
with this one so I'm going to leave that part of
the graph intact, then it's going to recalculate.
It's going to get both of its values and then
we're up to date. Are there any questions about
that? Okay so way clearer than I thought I was,
than I thought I was being, I guess or way less
clear, not sure. So the great thing about
this is that, this is a pattern that scales
really well. So a lot of the other Python web
application frameworks, they actually usually
have like several patterns embedded in them for
different levels of app complexity. So you write,
you know a Dash app, one way for when you're doing
a simple application and then another way when
you're using a more complicated one, you might be
using much more caching or something like that.
You might write a Streamlit app in one way at the
beginning, and then over time you need to kind of
manage state yourself, and I think similarly for
all of them Panel has three different basically
like APIs for updating different components. But
for Shiny, every app uses the same exact pattern
so when you kind of understand how this works at
this little toy level that we were talking about
you actually are really far along understanding it
at a much larger level. It works for dynamic AIs
and it's also UIs, and it's also lazy, so that's
kind of one of the reasons why some Shiny apps can
be so efficient because if we're back here right,
this is only because the user is trying to ask
for this. So if the user actually is not asking
for scatter plot, like it's not on the screen,
that it's on a background tab or something
like that Shiny just doesn't get around to
calculating. It never bothers to it, only does
that when it actually needs to or if you were
the developer like say it needs to recalculate
all the time. So, that kind of leads to these
types of efficient things, but where we're at
now is like just with what would you call like
flat reactive graphs where they all go input to
output, and there's another pattern that adds a
lot of depth to this thing which is reactive
calculations or in our reactive expressions.
So the decorator in Python is reactive calc, and
it basically like creates calculations that whose
results can be used by other renderers so it's not
rendering itself, it's something that you're going
to be able to pass on you could think of it just
like a reactive variable. So, here's an example,
so this is an application, this is again a kind
of silly toy application where we have a one
table and we have a uh a plot of some random data
and you know up here this kind of looks fine but
if I just sort of test it a little bit, and say I
produce like three values, you know maybe like
few more values you see we have like some of
these are not actually. Maybe I've actually,
yeah so this is a good example, so see here I have
like 0.13 and 0.12 two but over here on the plot
I have 0.8 and point and basically zero. So like,
what's going on, like why these, should these are
different and that's like a very confusing user
experience. And the reason they're different is
because I'm actually taking the sample twice
so this is the code for that application and
I have basically in the renderer this NP random
rand. So this is a numpy function that takes
a random sample and this is being produced here
and it's being produced here so these are going
to be different right because every time I do this
thing it's going to take a new the whole point of
that function is it takes a new sample and this is
kind of what that application looks like. I have
this one slider that's changing and I have sample
and table over here and sample and plot over here
and they're not going to be the same. So this is
both , there's a lot of problems with this code,
and in this case it's in defined in multiple
places, so I have to change it in multiple places.
The big problem is it's taking the sample twice so
it's not the same right, and that's going to cause
me a lot of headaches if I'm trying to like build
up intuition about how this sample works. And,
and they're not using the same sample so there's
an so if you use a reactive calculation what you
do or reactive expression in R, is you take that
code and you define it in a function, and you
decorate that function with reactive calc and then
when you're using it in your renderers you refer
to that function down here so you're not actually
taking the random sample there you're referring
to this bundle, and if this is a a regular
function that would just result in this same
behavior. Right, it would run through these things
every time it was called but a reactive function,
the first time it runs it caches its value and
then returns that cache value instead of rerunning,
and the main sort of thing that it does is adds
nodes to this reactive graph. So I'll just show
this to you in a in a in a picture because it's
it's a lot easier so this is kind of like again
Shiny starts out here with this, this table with
this reactive calculation and it doesn't know
the relationship between any of these things.
I'm putting this hierarchical, but it doesn't
even know that it's hierarchical it just knows
their things. So table runs, and when table runs,
it calls the sample reactive calculation and then
you run through the sample reactive calculation
and it says, oh I need slider it goes out and
gets slider and then Shiny has the relationship
between these three things. When the plot tries
to render it goes and tries to get sample but
since sample is a valid reactive, it hasn't been
invalidated, it's Shiny knows that it's correct
right slider hasn't changed since the last time
sample. It just returns the old value for plot,
so this makes it really good for some of these
situations of sampling where you need to make sure
that it's only to happening once, but it's also
great for just reducing complicated computation,
so this could be a long running model step or
a database query or something like that and it
would sort of automatically perfectly cache the
results for you. So then we have a deep, a deep,
reactive graph and these things can be stacked on
top of each other you don't need to have just one
layer of reactivity of reactives you could have
as many you want. So when the slider changes it
does the exact same process, so it follows that
down it says okay sample invalidated, and since
we're now in like a deep reactive graph sample has
to do one more thing which is or it has to do one
more thing which is like tell all the downstream
things to invalidate as well. And so it does that,
and then everything's invalidated and then it
does it again so it goes to the table gets the
sample. Sample runs goes and gets the slider
plot runs and so forth and then we have our
updated graph. And that's the end of what I was
going to talk about today. So I think that's kind
of like the basic idea of how reactivity works
for for both Shiny for R and Shiny for Python,
and I think we kind of master those little
like small things, as your app grows you can
kind of run into some bugs where really what's
happening is you're usually you're trying to
use an event driven pattern for when you
should be using a reactive one. But also
just helps you debug and figure out like why
is that not rendering you know it's probably
because there's some some sort of bug, so one of
these things is being detected in an unexpected
way. So a question from Amed:Are there limitations
on the number of intermediate calculations allowed
by Shiny? No, and this is one of the great things
about it is that you can have as many of these as
you want. I would say that there I mean there are
limitations just the more calculations you do the
slower your app is going to be but for the most
part, so long as you're like following like a non,
like do not repeat yourself, you can have as many
of them as you want. Like having something in a
reactive calculation is the most efficient way
that Shiny can render it, so that's your best
strategy rather than having logic sort of
uh split across renderers or anything like
that, so it's pretty hard. So the question
from Paul: What happens when your graph
contains cycles, so there is a function which
is, like so you're not, it causes a crash right
because it's like, it doesn't know how to
how to update things. There's a function,
show the screen again, so there's a way of kind
of starting, to so this is kind of like the
basics of reactivity. There's a lot of ways
of managing it manually, so one of them is,
sorry reactive isolate. So reactive isolate is
basically a way of like getting the value of
a of a re of reactive of an input or reactive
without drawing that reactive link. So this is
kind of like if you ever end up in a place where
you do have a cyclical graph usually like adding
and reactive isolate just breaks one part of that
to get out of that pattern. The other way that you
can work, the other thing that's handy is this
function, this decorator called reactive event,
which basically is a way of manually
drawing one of those things and saying
like only react to this one thing and not
anything else that I might be calling. So,
that we do have patterns for avoiding that,
but yeah you can't you're not allowed to have
it'll cause a a crash whenever you uh
have a circular graph dependency like
that. Any other questions or
we could also talk about other
things? Ah okay I do have the answer this, is
from, from Kelvin. When will the Shiny package
get its next update, and what will be in it?
Should be soon I don't know exactly when we're
doing the release. Maybe this week, this week
or next week. The main thing that's happening
there is we've had these components in
this experimental section over here,
just while we were kind of sorting out some of
the like some of the. One of, one of, our goals
is we want to have like the R and Python packages
like reused as much of the same code as we can,
so that we can make sure that when we're
developing something for R it comes to
Python quickly and vice versa so we had a lot of
conversations about how to do that, and we're done
with those. We're able to bring over basically all
of these experimental things into the main package
which makes you a lot easier to like use them.
So, that's the main thing that's coming next,
in this release. I think it's the the sort of
mostly what's in there and then yeah, we have
some other things around. I think tables is our
next main thing, thing we're going to keep working
on as well as making the sort of like really early
user experience of building Shiny apps easier to
kind of like simplify some of this stuff. Like
we have we've gotten some feedback where it's
like they like Shiny for complicated things, but
for simple things there's a little bit too much
boiler plate, too many decorators you know.
So trying to figure out how to simplify that,
but that'll probably not be next release but the
one after, but we should have a October release up
soon